this morning another major storm could
be headed to the Bahamas the last thing
they need a new system is taking shape
over the southern parts of the island
chain the storm is expected to approach
Florida as a tropical storm this weekend
by tomorrow it will pass Grand Bahama
which was devastated by hurricane durian
less than two weeks ago
Errol Barnett has been reporting in the
Bahamas for a week now and visited
hard-hit areas with former US Navy SEALs
he's at the airport in Nassau that's the
capital so Errol good morning to you and
what did you see well good morning the
the scene we found was heartbreakingly
familiar our journey to the most remote
parts of this country was only possible
through a combination of sea planes and
small boats and when we arrived at our
destination we found people suffering
with no cell service no running water
and no power for more than a week
this day's journey began with a seaplane
ride - to remote islands a mercy mission
delivering food and supplies organized
by a group of retired US Navy SEALs
based in South Florida
me and the guys my company it's
basically just the that continued want
to get back and just continue you know
serving after service
there's no landing area on Sweden's key
so we touch down on the open ocean
transferring to a small boat bringing
relief ashore our arrival an urgent
moment for the residents of this small
fishing community once home to around
100 people now only 26 remain hoping to
rebuild Nolan Cooper is one of those
survivors aid only began reaching his
community about four days ago more than
a week after the category-five monster
stalled directly on top of it for almost
30 straight hours are you still
surprised at how powerful this was
mine's brace they see this category 5
baiting those six the frustration here
is palpable many telling CBS News the
only assistance they've received has
come from foreigners from the US your
aid is coming from the US what are you
getting from the Bahamian government
nothing say it again now look the
government tells us that it is
coordinating relief efforts from here in
Nassau but because most of the field
teams are foreign and private aid groups
that's all that residents in the hardest
hit areas see as for the retired US
service members we spent the day with
they say they will continue running
these aid missions as long as they get
funding and donations and with this
storm rolling in they are now literally
racing the weather to get shelter to
those most in need Tony still a long way
to go there elbahr net force in the
Bahamas arrow thank you